Marius hey mr. music half the time he
had an accident when he was a kid we
still got a humming the drummer plays
music to drown it out that's what makes
it with best
aren't you mysterious maybe there's
business to the World Cup in the three
things money take the next
[Music]
you're going to get bloated wait I gotta
start the song over I'll pick up baby
you tell me who dies no I'm driving
[Applause]
some music nifA so you just starting
your day or did you just get off hey
call I go yeah so what is it you do I'm
a driver Oh like you're so far
anyone I'd know what is your name baby
your name's baby Bab why baby
[Music]
just one and say listen to the music all
the time
raise the mental mental meaning slow was
he slow no he had an accident when he
was a kid still has a hum in the drum
plays music to drown it out and that's
what makes him the best
[Music]
Oh more job and I'm done one more job
and we're straight now I don't think I
need to give you the speech at all what
happens when you say no how I could
break your legs and tell everyone you
love because you already know that onion
yeah
the moment you catch feeling there's a
moment your kitchen bully and you're a
waitress girlfriend she's cute keep it
that way
I want us to have oyster never stop he
wouldn't I'm in baby
[Music]
babe
underneath day baby you gotta get blood
on your hands
Claude first music
please get out of here I have to end
this are we in bed together now baby
doc said microwaves this is Mike Mayer
it should be the Halloween man forever
we met no the killer dual from Halloween
oh you mean Jason no baby you tell me
who does
she good girl you love her yes I do
that's too bad
you